okay got my own notification
okay i just hope
what's up everybody oh oh my gosh oh my
gosh oh my gosh oh my gosh oh my gosh oh
my gosh there's so many people
can you pull me up on your phone or
something
wow
the cosmic wonder
i can't keep up with the chat holy crap
i
i just wow this is so cool
oh where am i hello people hi
how's it going sorry i didn't realize i
was uh i didn't realize it wasn't on
screen
oh what's up guys how's it going who's
ready to watch it
how's it go how do i uh let's see i've
never streamed
from this type of system that i'm using
right now it's it's new
um so
everything seems to be fine right now
though we don't seem to have any
technical difficulties
so hello hi yes hello matthew stone
hello everybody ceramona
raphael mortal beast jordan phillip oh
i'm trying to say hi to everybody it's
uh
how's it going everybody jim christie
hey james what's up man how's it going
hey lakshith yep sorry if i can't
pronounce that right hey thank you
appreciate that aj do you have it pulled
up
hey from nigeria what's up benjamin
how's it going
thanks gloria uh it
is minecraft you see
uh i love minecraft it's so fun we were
uh
we we were going hard earlier today and
then i got off to sleep
and then everybody else in the room went
pretty hard too
uh what's up saturn what's going on
everybody wolf woof
bully mcguire love it oh from discord
what's up man yeah yeah yeah yeah
what's up marie elizabeth khalifa tyler
how's it going everybody
um agrawal love back to you richie rocks
love back to you how's it going everyone
so does everybody have their disney plus
pulled up because as soon as this
we have 21 minutes until it comes out
and we'll all watch together and just
react to it um
i i hope everyone knows that i can't
show it on my screen
so if you're looking for me to watch it
i'm sorry that that it can't happen
because
i'll get copy straight and i'll take my
channel down
uh what's up oogie how's it going how's
it
going
south africa wow dado datto however you
pronounce it i'm sorry if i pronounced
it wrong
um hopes up for seeing agent johnson and
the team
in the mcu uh
i don't know someone asked me the other
day they said
is the mcu going to go away in 10 years
or whenever they do their um
their secret wars movie which i am going
to stick by that's their next huge
avengers inning game
move that's what i entirely think um
i don't think gmc's going away like ever
so that's
that's just me um i don't really think
it's ever going away
i think they're just gonna make movies
until the end of time i don't know who's
gonna say
stop um you know kevin feige will
eventually step down and not be the
president of marvel studios that's
probably a very long way out eventually
he'll retire
and um you know somebody else come in
and
it's gonna be hard to replace kevin
feige but i don't think marvel's studios
in the marvel cinematic universe is ever
going to go away
i i just don't think that's ever going
to happen
so woof how's it going everybody
i am doing good muhammad thank you
peyton i feel you i gotta do like the
breakdown videos and everything
even though i'm like a slacker because
i've already seen the first three
and chris my editor my co-host of uh
cosmic culture was like well you can do
the videos in advance you've already
seen them i'm like oh my gosh i totally
can
and i was gonna do it today but um got a
little busy
minecraft hey philippines playing disney
plus how's it going
tekken gaming with revenge how's it
going patrick kane what's up everybody
how's it going
greetings from wakanda awesome awesome
awesome awesome awesome
awesome glad everybody could be here we
have
what do we have here 17
something like that 17 minutes i think
yeah let's get it
yeah i'm excited for two yeah morbius
was delayed
uh i don't remember when it was delayed
to if we go
to my twitter though i put it
somewhere
uh if we go i know i put it in here
somewhere
you never like realize how much you post
on something until
you like go back and look uh let's see
oh
october 8th it was right there morbius
delayed to october 8th
2021 which is like
now it's after venom yeah
it's after venom hey jason what's going
on man
hey thank you so much super appreciate
that let me go back to the screen so i
can like toggle everything
super appreciate that jason
thanks for the donation uh when does it
come out
it comes out so it's 12 43 right now
and it comes out at 101 for me
hey thanks nilon appreciate that
hey thank you shawshwat experiments
appreciate that
so i'm just going to tell you a little
bit about what i hey
brianna how's it going hey i actually i
know your picture
oh thank you so much i'm i'm happy i
actually i
totally remember your comments i
remember your comments and i
i definitely remember your picture and i
know i've commented back to you a few
different times
so thank you for stopping by thanks for
the donation and uh i'm glad i'm glad i
could help thank you
could i put on subtitles uh for myself
i don't think that can happen
so that one plays yes i do
i do i do
um again guys i i i know a lot of people
i know some people might might think
that i can show it on my screen i can't
i'm sorry
um this is for all of us to watch it on
our own and react together and talk to
each other and then after i'm gonna talk
about what we
saw um i've already seen it i've seen
the first three the first two
are coming out in 15 in 16 minutes
and then uh next friday is when episode
three drops and that's all i've seen up
to so far i truly if you watch my review
i truly think this is like
one of the funniest shows i've seen like
it's so funny it's so good
i love it uh no james i can't i can't
stream like
any of the show unfortunately hey love
from india
arshad kamala love back
back to india i know i have a lot of
people who watch from india whoa
hey
thank you so much for that donation also
do
what you do i also make i also do what
you also make more
videos on marvel you see md c z
channel with somebody to be as
successful as you it was just awesome
hey i super appreciate that
just you have to keep going right
because there's
i think the biggest thing with like
youtubers is they stop
and they let like bad views get them
down or no views get them down and
trust me i've been there um cosmic
wonder wasn't just
like an overnight success right um
when infinity war and everything like
picked up
really fast i i did gain a lot of
traction but it didn't happen overnight
there was a lot of
am i going to be able to make this like
my actual career is this what i'm going
to do
it it's hard so no matter what you just
keep going man just keep going
hold on i missed some i'm trying to
madago thank you so much
super appreciate that madugo 73
thank you so much i'm trying not to miss
any of the donations
i don't want to be that guy ivan i'm the
thank you you're the best hey i
recognize your uh i recognize your
your picture your logo there
the gamer uh
hey ariel prado thank you appreciate
that
um what did you think why doctor strange
didn't fight thanos in the game
because he saw how it was supposed to
play out so he
he just let that happen you know what i
mean let me go back over here
he just let that happen
so
hey thank you peyton i super appreciate
that super super appreciate
that god of thunder what's up love from
bangladesh what's up phpd
how's it going everybody rashad
rahee i think that says
potato boy what's up carlos
ruhi shane what's up everybody austin123
hey what's up man
what is up everybody
thought i was star-lord for a second
that's a compliment
that's a super compliment i can't show
the episodes i'm sorry i
really am sorry i really wish i could um
i will kind of flash
some things really really quickly but
beside i can't they'll take down my
channel
um and i know
hi big fan do you think time traveling
game was really a loophole
um i don't know what you mean by a
loophole
um oh what's up joe
captain maximoff that's funny yeah yeah
yeah we've been commenting a lot to each
other
recently i'm not sure what you mean by
loophole but i think they had a plan to
use time travel to like
you know make it to where um
they put all the stones back and nothing
was gonna go wrong right but obviously
things happen loki got away on things
like that
and when you mess with time it tends to
mess back like tony stark said
and you can never expect something like
that and i'm talking about it like it's
real
which you know it's not at least i think
it's not i'm not a scientist
um talk about like it's real it when you
mess with stuff like that it's like so
hard to not
mess it up in some way or another that's
why kang's coming in and that's why the
tva the time variance authority is
coming in
and loki series looks amazing and when
you guys watch this series it's so
different like it is so
different than anything i've seen marvel
do and that gives me
like so much hope and excitement for the
future of marvel
because you guys will see don't expect a
lot
um like the villains not gonna get
revealed
tonight you won't see like the villain
in the first two episodes
they'll hint at it there's some really
cool easter eggs and you're gonna be
like whoa whoa whoa whoa
oh hey hey bang guy the show glad to
finally watch party 10
oh hey appreciate that welcome welcome
welcome welcome welcome welcome
i want to make sure i didn't miss any
here
hey so yeah good job i'm never going to
stop buddy because always hey
awesome keep going man just keep going
keep going keep going
um that's what i always say that's
that's just what i always say about
about youtube about anything
um before i did youtube you could barely
hear me
can you hear me more here let me pull
something up
i think i think it's uh
i think the audio's all right if you
can't uh
if you can't hear me i would oh check it
on your end seems like everybody can
hear me
i have it on my phone here just to make
sure i'm not having any like
typic technical problem so extra what's
up from florida hey i used to live in
florida i grew up in florida was born in
florida my whole life
i think it's i think the audio is all
right
oh wow it's super delayed i just
realized that it's super delayed wow
okay
okay thank you as i the warrior you can
hear me cool cool cool cool
well marvel sure does like to wait till
or not even marvel disney hey woof woof
captain thunder woof woof look carter
i love you three thousand chat atharva
shukla i'm so sorry if uh if i'm not
pronouncing
all these right do i know when you get
disney plus in the philippines no i'm
sorry
i don't i don't know when i hope soon i
hope soon i have a couple friends in the
philippines actually
um you can use a vpn
um i actually don't know what vpn but
you can use a vpn
um and it'll set it to like you're in a
different country
what's up i respect it it's at least in
nine minutes yes i've paid money
to say this yeah what's up joshua
how's it going uh but you could use a
vpn um uh
i missed a dono who did i miss oh no i'm
so sorry if i missed it
terribly sorry oh avik das
love from india love your veggies hey
super appreciate that and that's an
awesome logo right there and thank you
who told me that i missed the donut i
really i'm really not trying to miss any
i'm not trying to be that guy
because i super appreciate any support
any sport at all um
kind of talking back to you know the
people were asking about youtube because
you get asked about youtube a lot
um one is start because people always
ask me like what do i do to start a
youtube channel what is you just have to
start
like don't wait i i would like wait
until
like i remember i posted my first video
and then i didn't post another video
until like
i think like a couple weeks later and
then like a month after that
because i i thought videos had to be
perfect i thought
i had to have like all this good
equipment and stuff like that
but really you you just have to start
that's all it takes because i think
about mr beast who started
with his phone and it was like a really
really really terrible phone
right um
and look where he is now 50 million i
think he just hit
maybe 60 50 million i think it just hit
so um
bad guy i got you though guys it
releases in
eight minutes eight minutes
so have your disney plus ready everybody
have your
disney plus ready because we're all
gonna go at the same time
we're all gonna watch it together um
i'll point out some things that i
noticed the first time that i watched it
uh love from greece wow
i've already had nord vpn sponsorships
but it's over with i don't get anything
for it now but i i tell everybody the
same thing
if you are um hey super exposed
uh if you're looking for i love you 3000
that's for
a tharva skulka show club sorry i'm so
i'm so bad at pronouncing names um
i can't share the full episode guys i'm
really really sorry i can't show
almost any of it because youtube and
disney will take my channel down
sorry this is kind of like normal watch
parties on youtube or so like everybody
can kind of like watch at the same time
because i know a lot of people
the ones who do have disney plus are
just sitting here ready it starts in
seven minutes now and we're gonna hit
play at the same time we're gonna watch
at the same time
um did i miss this donation so sorry
oh okay oh my uh wow i just realized
that youtube is uh
there's like a five minute delay i
didn't even realize that so
if i'm a little delayed i'm replying to
you guys i i apologize for that
thank you i love you 3000 as well rob
what time is in india riju love back to
india
i i see a lot of uh people from india in
here
um uh the canadian lab collab went out
i don't uh i don't remember how long ago
maybe like
three four weeks ago uh one division has
nine episodes
nine episodes one division
uh i've seen three episodes sam brown
uh disney sent me the first three
episodes and then after and we're
getting two tonight
and next friday the third one's gonna
come out ah crap
my roommate's cat just ran in my room oh
he went my room
hey thank you nico pie
uh greg greg abba from real rejects just
texted me so i was like i had to say
what's up to him
all right guys five minutes
get your disney plus ready
hello kitty guys this is felix
he's a bengal cat
what you doing felix this is a bengal
say hi chris
this is chris everyone from culture
captains nope from cosmic culture
we've bought two channels we've
what's up man i saw that i saw your
comment how's it going
this is better than twitch
hey thank you i'm gonna try to pronounce
this krish
nanchu day krishnan thank you
appreciate that thanks goodbye felix i
also have two cats as well
so we got a lot of cats running around
everywhere so if you see them
uh yeah well we have three cats in our
house you love cats as well
cool cats are awesome i love animals in
general
hey ben guy he left but i'll tell him
tomorrow
hey love from egypt wow what's up marvin
that's crazy it's crazy crazy crazy
crazy
have you seen the twins already i have
as babies
i think i think i'm getting that i think
i'm getting that pronouncing down
that's down how do you know what time is
it india guys 1 30 pm in india thank you
priyanch for telling me that uh how do
you use a vpn in india how to use vpn
india
um so basically you go download a vpn
there's
a few trustworthy ones out there um
sometimes they sponsor me
hold on darion soto
darian soto however you pronounce that
i'm sorry if i mispronounced it hey
warren love your channel who's someone
you're hoping it makes appearance one
division series
huh let's see um
i doctor doom first first and foremost
doctor doom
uh eunice i am so excited too thank you
so much for that donation thank you
thank you thank you so much
super excited eunice um back to darian
i want doom to make an appearance
because there's a lot of connections
uh to wanda specifically her mother
and vundegor where she's from uh i'm
sorry i meant doctor doom's mother
there's a lot of connections and
especially with harkness
and i think it would make really good
sense and i also just want dr doom
because i truly believe
everything's building up the secret wars
alright guys get your disney plus ready
because we have two minutes until this
comes out
so to use a vpn i'll address this real
fast to use a vpn
you just download a vpn and then in the
vpn you can show
you can change your location so you can
actually say that you're in america
and then you could access like netflix
or
uh disney plus because it acts like
you're in america
so you have access to it so anyone who
can't do that you can get a vpn
so a lot of them are cheap like you can
get a vpn for like
i think a few bucks a month
like four or five bucks a month i think
so all right
what's up darren yeah thank you for the
donation thank you thank you all who
done
hey jordan barrett hey you hey you nice
batman shirt in the in the logo thank
you so much for the donation
oh bang guy uh
i did i never did watch watch parties
before star wars theory did the man lore
now i can't
not have one yeah they're a lot of fun
and that's the point
of these is uh so we can have fun
together all right guys
let's see where it's at
is it up it is 101
season one episode one we are about to
hit
the start button so everyone have your
disney plus
up we're about to watch it right now
and three
two one
here we go
let's go let's go let's go let's go
let's go let's go let's go let's go
new marvel studios logo
hey thank you for the nice guitar yes i
do play guitar i love music
i will do this for all disney plus
releases francesco yes i will
all right we're getting past the marvel
season here we go here we go
laughs
[Laughter]
the theme song is like really cool
i can't screen share it guys disney will
delete my youtube channel
uh
[Laughter]
that is stormbreaker in the background
flying saucer
[Laughter]
laughs
[Laughter]
foreign
[Laughter]
oh i love it
let return
hahaha
uh
uh
[Music]
laughs
uh
hahaha
oh oh this is pretty good vision at this
job
g willikers that was fast
all right super quick leak
super quickly
yes but what is it we're producing
computational that's
all that's happening right no one can
process the data quite like you do pal
you're like a that's all that's
happening his vision is at work
whoops
hahaha
yeah every now and then i'll i'll show
some shots of what's
what's happening guys
excuse me
i don't have a skeleton sir
so juana thinks it's their anniversary
because they had something marked on the
calendar but really it's
visions boss is coming over to visit
them so this
or so one is prepping for like a
romantic night with vision but vision
is bringing his boss over after work
hey what's up devil power
laughs
vision residence
laughs
hey thank you karthik
[Laughter]
hey what's up everyone gamer how's it
going
oh easter egg easter egg
this really cool easter egg here
did you see it
it's a little logo on the bottom right
they mentioned it too
by stark industries
so they show like a little ad and it's
for stark industries
it's like a toaster made by stark
industries
just a little tiny easter egg
[Laughter]
hahahahahahahaha
oh
[Laughter]
it did right yeah it made like the
repulsor sound it's pretty cool
[Laughter]
hahaha
uh disney will delete my channel if i
show it because they will copyright it
which is super against the law
so streaming this or sharing it is
illegal
um
here's the tiny little easter egg
there it is this is by stark industries
that's what they did
it's yeah it's a very different show
i love deborah joe rupp she's so good
oh you can hear it now oh
oh there's no volume on you should be
able to
yes exactly minutiae thanks for
explaining that i can't share
i can't share the screen guys
so basically all that's happening right
now is that
wanda is cooking a dinner for vision's
boss
and his boss's wife is over and it's not
going very well
it's just a lot of slapstick comedy
right now
hey thank you tony appreciate that
[Laughter]
fred
hahaha
episode should be available right now it
should all be on disney plus right now
deborah drop is freaking classic love
her
uh this episode is 27 minutes long
i got the agnes the nosy neighbor agnes
at least is
what they're caller
you could use a vpn to watch it hey
imperfect lioness
awesome glad you're loving it
tonight's going swimmingly purchasy
[Laughter]
my wife's head is spinning generally i
don't like her head to do that
keep refreshing if you can't stream it
guys it's on disney plus right now
european
hey thank you andrew appreciate that
this part's so good right here
[Laughter]
amen
so
this is where it gets weird
yeah it just went horror it went horror
for like a good minute
like super weird vibes
such slapstick jokes in this they're so
good
hey cool [ __ ] raj thank you love back to
india
hey vision getting a promotion
it's completely relevant to the plot but
it's the it's ending the episode
it's ending the episode right now give
you a little tiny
little look and that's all it is
and the rings i'm just gonna make
can't rings make some rings for us
oh
oh they just said i do
i'll show some clips after this i like
i'll freeze frame some things i can do
that
they have their rings now
wanda maximoff and vision oh okay hold
on
it's not over yet if you're watching
it's not over yet
so
written by jack schaefer so that was
like really really really good
so there's nothing else if you're
watching it with me there's there's no
post credit scene or anything like that
so we're just gonna go ahead and we're
gonna start the second uh
we'll start the second episode i will
show uh like screenshots really quick
here hold on
let's show a couple screenshots really
quick just so you guys can kind of get
like a taste of oops i did something
wrong
all right so i'll show just like a few
a few clips or a few screenshots from
this so
though the the
uh visions boss comes over after work um
it's kind of funny because there's like
a mix up there's a miscommunication
between one division
i'm not going to like say all of it
because i know some are watching it but
don't want the spoilers
um but at the end there's one part
this part look how like i love deborah
jorok
but look how scary that is it gets dark
like this part right here gets dark
and it's pretty crazy it's
it's pretty crazy it's pretty crazy
i totally am watching tom and jerry
absolutely um i don't know why it's not
working on disney plus guys just i if
it's not just keep refreshing it um
yeah the credits are cool it's a cool
little scene but
um you know at the end this is dumb
right here
um and yeah
it's black and white the entire episode
the entire episode
here's a little cool i wanted to show
this here's a little cool
what the heck let me show it this is if
you can see right here
this is made by stark industries so it's
pretty cool
pretty pretty pretty pretty pretty cool
um
and it's just a little call back to tony
stark right or
i mean yeah tony stark but at this point
time is definitely howard
but it's pretty cool down here it says
dark industries too so
it's pretty cool it's pretty cool i wish
i could stream the whole thing so you
guys can see it but
copyright law we are going to start the
second episode now
guys if it's not up for you i i i'm
sorry i really
i'm really not sure what to tell you
um just keep refreshing and refreshing
and refreshing
uh it came up for me kind of right away
um yeah as you can see it's right here i
have it right here on disney plus
so um
i don't know oh that's true yeah
the toaster did kind of flash a little
bit you right deputy
uh i don't know i don't know why they're
so short
that is a mystery to me
oops let me try to bring something up
here
how come oh this isn't working for me
i guess not
huh weird okay well uh
let's start the second episode whoever
is
let me just do one thing
all right let's start the second episode
for all those you watching we're about
to
hit play on
this and again i'm sorry i can't show
the entire thing that's where we're at
and we're into the second episode let's
go
the intro is just previously in one
division
uh there is a cat somewhere
um i i believe it's related to the house
of m
yes uh there's some very creepy
very very very creepy things in this um
very very creepy parts in this yes
and especially in i think it's the third
episode
i don't think it's in this episode this
this episode is really really funny the
second episode
it's really really really funny but the
third episode gets
kind of dark so yeah it it it is i think
and it's pretty much confirmed that it
is very heavily like tying into house of
m
so
so now is the scene where the scene i'm
watching right now you've seen before
it's where the beds are separating
and there's like a noise outside
are you using your night vision vision
they really do have some good puns in
the show like
like i've been saying like the slapstick
i think it's mephisto but it hasn't been
revealed yet i don't want to spoil
anything and to be truthful they don't
really
show you the villain not the first three
episodes at least
what if i should
sorry oh
oh put the beds together
this is my cat rocket hi
say hi to everybody it's pizza time
this intro is so cool it's like a
bewitched intro
here you go babe oh
no don't get up there get down there
here i will show you a brief
how how they're doing this one really
right here
uh there's like this is like the
animation from like the beginning
this is kind of how they're doing it
they're like showing
one division like that
kind of like that it's pretty cool how
they do it and just like the intro for
it
so then we get into this which is like
the
the magic stuff that we've been uh that
we've been seeing before
there we go
cabinet of mysteries
uh i believe so drove
it's pizza time it's pizza time
[Laughter]
abracadabra hey what's up legendary one
it's stormbreaker
and a real magic act everything is fake
woof
no we shall
uh so wanda just wants them to fit in
and they're prepping for uh
a community talent show fundraiser right
now and that's when
all those leaks you've seen about like
the magic act that's what's happening
right now
woof woof gargey love back to india
max winder good evening to you as well
paul bettany in this episode is amazing
he's fantastic in this episode
love back to india drove um oh
a wand z zavok
i know that's greek and i i can't really
read it but i tried my best
thanks for all the cool comments
hey thank you i like my room too i put a
little bit of work into it
thank you raj appreciate that uh noop
joseph hi
joji prakash hi my cat's name is rocket
after rocket raccoon
yes anakin skywalker he is awesome
alright serious moment it's getting
weird
sword logo
i'll pause this part for you guys so you
can see it
hey thank you marvel i'll pause this
part so you can see it
so
so you can very clearly see the sword
logo on this helicopter right
there on this helicopter it's the only
thing in color
sword logo right on it
catherine's character so good
thanks siddharth
yes but it's too late for that
yes and here she is
a dottie
what a name a dottie
i know the live audience is really like
really really really really cool
uh
that right there is a mephisto
easter egg
i'll take a look at that while i'm
working a bit
hmm
i think it's mephisto
when the part with the talent show comes
up i'll i'll show you some uh
some stills of it
oh and then vision going to his meeting
now at the west view public library
yes i'm watching in one division right
now i'm sorry i can't show it
i'll show random clips here and there
sort of a members only type deal
another round of danish dude that dude's
mustache is crazy
vision i don't eat food
[Laughter]
hey horizons eclipse
i'm gonna check that out in just a
second and thank you for the donation
i know you said it just to get me to see
that but uh
yeah i'll take i'll take a look at it
327 i remember that
it's so that era
i'm as round as they come
oh this is awesome
um i don't know where you can watch free
no i'm sorry
yeah i can't i can't show it bully
mcguire because of copyright
hey yousef how's it going
they haven't revealed how vision's alive
yet uh they actually don't reveal that
in the entire first three episodes
vision 8 gum and it like went down into
his body and it like got
stuck inside it's like kind of messing
them up it's really funny
everything is still in black and white
too
uh i don't know the upcoming movie name
for spider-man michelle i still think
it's home worlds but i don't know
hey thank you on god
serious now
i don't believe
wanda can you read me
who are you
so creepy
so creepy
i can't show the screen i can't show the
screen
um i've seen three episodes already yes
and i'm sorry i can't show the screen
guys i will show random screenshots like
right now i'll show a random screenshot
oh wait big easter egg here
then i'll show it strucker
strucker hydra literally here i'll show
you real quick
strucker hydra watch
look at that look at that
that's a crazy easter egg
talent showtime
oh vision paul bettany is amazing in the
scene
baron vonstrucker
it's like vision's drunk i love it
man the boy
oh my gosh
uh don't know about two monikas i think
just one
all i've seen so far
oh this is so good
yeah uh vision 8 gum and it's like
messing up his inside so it's like he's
drunk now it's really funny
wanda and vision for the final act
i don't know if you can tag anyone on
here exopotic
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
drunk vision
illusion
um it's out on disney plus right now
just keep refreshing
now we'll check out 327 in a bit
vision is flying
i'm feeling kooky i'm on episode two
episode two right now
um it's the talent show
i don't know
that's my grandma's brand now here i'll
give you a quick little look at just
this little talent show that they're
doing right now
it's uh it's pretty good it's pretty
good
i think only one monica rambo in the
series not two
this god
this is good
paul vetten is so good
uh next friday episode 3 being released
hahaha
uh i do think doctor jim's gonna be set
up
the cabinet of mysteries
uh nine episodes are being released in
total for one vision
make my wife disappear
oh catherine hann's so good
she's not in it yet
uh today is one one and two
what's in the box uh yes it is storm
breaker the legendary one and yes i am
live streaming
thai awesome
monica
i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm sorry
i've been feeling weirdy all day give
you guys a brief
a brief another look in here
so vision ate a stick of gum and he's
like drunk because of the gum
oh
you too stop
drunk gum evie son that's funny
uh it's all in black and white still
nothing color yet
oh my gosh paul bettany killed in this
episode
oh
they got the inaugural comedy
performance of the year
hey infinite blazer it's finally playing
awesome
uh the surprise character is not in this
episode it's an episode three which
comes out on friday
oh i'm so sorry dirty gertie yeah just
keep refreshing i'm sorry
[Music]
for the children yeah right
it's amazing right yeah i'm still not
done yet we're in 26
minutes
oh they won a trophy i'll show you guys
some
stills from this episode after
all for the children
oh she's pregnant
if it's that i can't believe they said
damn
because back then you could not curse at
all
yeah it gets scary real fast you're
right about that
one of the characters in this this one
right here
dude the vibe gets so creepy
no
house of m right there that was all just
house of them
she changed it she changes the reality
to fit her circumstances
vision is now in color
and everything changes to in color
and yes i will show you guys in just a
second
everything's a color now and one
division
and episode is
over
oh it gets so creepy sometimes it gets
creepy sometimes
yes so what you just said uh ryan
there was reference to the devil
and to me that's mephisto
it was referenced like twice like how
you don't reference the devil
you don't reference the devil
specifically without it being mephisto
like it's
it's mephisto like that's what it is so
okay
um i can show you guys
a little bit now i can't screen it
again because copyright um
but i can kind of go through a few
different parts now
part at the end where it goes in color
it was so good right i'm so
i'm so glad i'm i'm sorry to all the
people
who have disney plus and it's not out
right now i don't
i don't know i don't know why i don't
know why it's out it worked it was
like the second it hit 1201 it was up
for me on my disney plus
um yeah so they yeah
exactly what you said channeling j
they referenced the j they referenced
the devil a lot
they were so like there's a few times i
referenced them
and uh let's let's go check something
real fast so everybody's been talking to
me about
at 3 27
at 3 27 there's a
there's a galactus
helmet
oh dang it my internet's like all
screwed up right now
uh guys if i lose the internet i will be
right back for it uh
uh hey if i lose the internet i will be
live
right back again because it doesn't seem
to be kind of working for me right now
we're not sure who the b guy is yet like
we don't know who the b guy is yet uh i
have
kind of theories but i mean i don't know
like it's it's kind of like very
confusing like
b guy like who's the big guy i i don't
know why
like why i
i don't understand so this this
this second episode is one that i
particularly enjoyed hey
penguin thanks for the donation yeah
they are they are sick uh
and definitely a lot of breakdowns
coming in within the next few days
because there's a lot to break down here
la la la la to break down here um what's
up muhammad